for baba haidara this day should have
come 18 years ago the alleged killer of
his father journalist daeda hydera
finally on trial not in the gambia where
his murder took place but in germany
it's a significant moment not just for a
son but for a country still healing
after more than two decades of often
violent rule under president yahya
jammeh
we
say
this is a day we've been waiting for for
18 years so it's a big day for justice
for my family and myself who started
this journey in 2004.
this is the beginning of a long road
because lowe is just one of the accused
there are others and the most important
one is
who we hope one day to see in front of a
tribunal
bailout is accused of crimes against
humanity and murdering two people at the
request of jamie he allegedly worked as
a driver for the junglers a death squad
that underpinned jammeh's 22-year reign
by silencing his critics and he is the
first alleged member of the gang to go
on trial
we welcome the fact that germany has now
taken the first step
there are other proceedings around the
world there is a procedure in
switzerland and one in the us
in particular we hope that this will
give a boost to justice efforts in the
gambia and that those responsible there
will also be brought to justice
jeremy's regime was notorious for
crushing dissent through murder
disappearances torture rape and
castration his successor adam abaro set
up a south african style truth and
reconciliation commission to probe
allegations of abuses
low is being tried under the principle
of universal jurisdiction allowing a
foreign country to prosecute crimes
against humanity regardless of where
they were committed
analysts say within the gambia there was
not only a lack of judicial resources to
bring about justice but a lack of
political will
so it tells us one thing that you know
perpetrators that are in the gambia as
well as the gambia government is
concerned perfectos that are here will
may probably some of them not all but
some of them will likely escape and
punishment but those that are outside
the gambia and of course other countries
are interested using the principle of
universal jurisdiction
we'll have to deal with them and those
people will have to face justice at the
end of the day
back in the gambia the case is being
watched closely and many hope jammeh
himself will eventually face justice
charlie angela al jazeera